em 90 norberto
vou dizer quanto dissesse que teve que
ser uma família e eu não sei como vai
ser este natal acho que vou ter de vir à
minha mãe para me sentar à mesa
é o que eu trago hoje é uma história
curiosa
vou dar o nome de miguel até porque não
quero que vocês percebam que fui eu o
tinha 18 anos estava na praia estava no
final do dia e não estava a praticar
surf até porque o desporto não é uma
coisa que eu acho que muito está vendo
que o pôr do sol mais ou menos até o pôr
do sol
assim pra cima transmitir abaixo o
morais é no qual é rock estuprar um
daltônico não conseguiu visualizar
aquela cor até por miguel este verde é
brutal deste desta pena e entretanto
miguel
naquele instante estava policiar o pôr
do sol estava muito bem acompanhado na
altura como sempre ao e também como é a
companhia feminina sms exatamente a
primeira série este poder correr bem não
fosse a companhia feminina que estava o
avião e memorável e garantidamente não
tenha sido ela a enviar um sms
temos aqui um instante que é uma
vivência das emissões com base na
ciência com base nos artigos em estudos
remoções sejam os cientistas dizem nos
casos onde estão na base do
comportamento
eu nem quero imaginar o que estava
acontecendo aqui é um instante como é
que o pastor daquela emoção prazerosa de
estar na que o pôr do sol
o sms principalmente justificação é que
a hungria a namorada uma coisa dessas
envolveu um dia mais tarde o filme
ofendeu ter feito um contrato de
fidelização com serviço de psiquiatria
psiquiatria e na psicologia do hospital
mais próximo e ter feito uma tendência
abusiva do mesmo aviso apenas com uma
coisa mais ou menos entrou em depressão
e bater com a cabeça oca
a coisa tem que resolver muito bem
porque eu só durou dois meses que foi na
altura em que o encontrou é tal furna
que tinha dito que ia ser pai ea onde
diz a não há problema
salvo engano num sms era como lembrado
pois vai eu queria entrar eu não crio em
ciência da escuta e nós a ser brincamos
não é
brincamos os marotos oeste o quadrinho
vamos fazer um cliente ciência nós temos
dedicado os últimos tempos
a investigação das invenções como outras
equipas a nível internacional o que nós
sabemos é que as emissões têm colados
eletrofisiológicos não liga às centrais
e periféricas a soja que ocorrem aqui
dentro do nosso século e que também são
produzidas no restante do corpo podem
ser recolhidos em vídeo e acima de tudo
nós temos aí padrões das funções porque
nós queremos perceber acima de tudo o
que tinha acontecido naquela história
como esta história é aplicável a todas a
tantas outras
nós queremos saber o que estava
acontecendo e por que eu tenha tomado
aquela que os comportamentos foram
probatória que o que nós vamos precisar
é participante para começarmos a ler
estas medidas e vamos precisar de
testemunhas o que nós vamos fazer com
isto temos tudo serve para nós induzimos
os novos participantes e recolhermos
então os sinais que estão a produzir que
sair novamente repito medidas centrais
ou então prefere casas e já vamos um
carrinho em mais à frente
ouvir os colegas nossos do outro lado do
atlântico
não lhe cidade da flórida ou seja muitos
apartamentos ambiental do instituto
nacional da flórida criaram duas bases
de dados
investimos em duas dimensões 1 com
fotografias que ea psa e outro de sons
digitais que o goiás nós em portugal
conseguimos juntar o melhor dos dois
mundos e fizemos como base dados do
filme
até porque cada vez que eu ia ao cinema
havia pessoal harris eo pessoal também
vim pessoal a chorar e é um povo
guerreiro também vi pessoal não fazerem
essas coisas com os quatro mas foi aí
que nós juntamos fizemos um costa
juntamente com o ipanema universidade da
beira interior ea universidade de aveiro
e fizemos esta batata esta base de dados
ou levarmos esta base de dados para a
população portuguesa não tem nome fato
dizem então com o padrinho está aqui
este é o primeiro desafio vamos lançar o
desafio a terex até porque esta é uma
prestação beta certo onde está certo a
apresentação beta
ok e então vamos lançar o desafio será
em vocês
eventualmente sugerir o nome presta as
datas científica que nós fizemos de
forma o valor para todo mundo vai ser
publicado não sairei por quantos dias só
quantas horas só quantos minutos mas
também não interessa é no facebook do
telex o porto essa sugestão basta
comentarem com o vosso nome é ea
sugestão do nome e depois no nome o
vosso nome ea sugestão do nome da base
dados que depois eventualmente nós vamos
premiar com alguém até porque temos hoje
5 que o sul 4-1 imagine o que é que
vocês podem fazer 12 vai como é que como
como é que escolhemos os dados
recolhidos com tecnologia que é maioria
vocês conhecem desde
eletroencefalografia desde a
eletrocondutividade papel desde o
tracking desde eletrocar de grafia
até mesmo assim era um tre até que tudo
vai mas nós ainda fizemos uma coisa mais
interessante foi sincronizar toda esta
tecnologia
enquanto alguns nós algo enquanto alguns
colegas nós tiravam sinais com estas
tecnologias e essas técnicas
isoladamente nós temos seguimos
sincronizar e simboliza porque o filme
para extrair os tais padrões dois quilos
permitam fazer o movimento e fazer a
cartografia destas funções como elas
acontecem dentro do sistema nervoso
central e também prefere qo mas aqui há
uma coisa que ainda não disputou ainda
muito grande estou ainda muito mais em 3
sandra eu avisar e não tive a minha
questão é como é que nós passávamos de
uma injunção para a outra
esta foi a nossa grande preocupação como
é que nós enquanto seres humanos
passamos de uma emoção pra outra função
e isso permite-nos então com base nestes
padrões desenvolver algoritmos técnicas
e métodos de cálculo para podermos
produzir novas técnicas de recolha e
interação
nós estamos agora um crime num exercício
fôssemos um exercício de futurologia
temos a certeza que está na base temos
quase a certeza porque queremos
acreditar enquanto cientistas enquanto
investigadores que estamos a criar algo
que nos vai permitir desenvolver métodos
novos métodos e novas técnicas para
detetar em funções
queremos acreditar que dentro de algum
tempo vamos desenvolver novos métodos e
novas técnicas para induzir emoções e
queremos acima de tudo acreditar que
estes estudos e esta razão nós estamos a
preparar hoje vai permitir desenvolver
novas técnicas e novos métodos de
detecção de comportamento
será que estamos na base ou no início
atenção dos processos de tomada de
decisão que é isso que interroga a
maioria de nós como é que nós teríamos
porque se vive por aqui um pouquinho ou
por aquilo
será que mais tarde nós não vamos buscar
o momento de conseguirmos prever qual é
a escolha vão terminar do consumidor
teremos nós gostaríamos nós é
desenvolver mecanismos para interação de
provisão comportamental
chan o miguel carvalho e adora estar
aqui e eu também
obrigado